it's not your job to create  your vision it's your job to have a  vision  and then it's your job to hire talented  individuals to hire talented artists who  understand your vision you don't need to  know anything about sewing to have  wonderful costumes in your films you  just need to express what you want to  the costume designers you don't need to  have an engine a degree in engineering  to have magnificent sets in your pieces  you need to describe what it is you want  you don't need to know how to take a  bunch of different light stands and put  them together to create a specific  lighting effect that's not your job you  don't need to know any of that what you  need to know is you need to have a  vision and you need to know how to  express it and then you let the other  people take it and do it for you that is  what a director does